at least 36 people have been killed in a
train crash in taiwan
dozens more were injured in the accident
in which the train derailed
after emerging from a tunnel and
colliding with the truck
survivors were seen climbing out of
windows and onto roofs to reach safety
rescuers are still trying to reach
passengers trapped
in some of the carriages
uw correspondent william yang has the
latest for us from taipei william dozens
of deaths have already been confirmed
by police what more do we know
we know that most of the deaths and the
serious injured
are all in car seven and eight and
that's
initially where the inspectors believe
that the truck hit
the head of the car eight of the train
and caused it
some of its uh trains to hit the wall of
the tunnel
and then cause it to derail in the end
so what is the situation then right now
william
so rescuers are still trying to uh
evacuate those that are still trapped in
cars seven and eight where we know
a lot of these bodies are still lying on
the ground
according to some of the passengers who
got out safely
and then also at the same time they were
still trying to clear out the carriages
because
as we know the train occupies a very
important
train rail line that goes down the north
end and the south end of taiwan's east
coast
and this is the first day of a long
weekend where a lot of the passengers
are expecting to be
relying on this railway to go home to
the eastern part of taiwan
so if they cannot clear out all the
trains from the tracks
in time it could create a chaos for this
long weekend
okay and and obviously there's been a
human toll here as well
just just walk us through how this
happened we understand that a truck
caused the accident didn't it
right so information right now shows
that
a driver of a truck which is uh
conducting some
constructions nearby uh did not park the
truck properly
it parked he parked the car on a slope
and then he did not uh pull the brakes
properly and then the truck
unfortunately
slide down the slope and then ran into
the
railway and then at the at around the
same time the train was trying to enter
into the tunnel and then so
the truck hit the head of the car a
where the conductor's room was
there and then uh that caused the whole
train to the rail in the end and then
caused one of the deadliest uh
accident in decades in taiwan and right
now we also know that unfortunately
the conductor is confirmed dead as one
of the 36 people
and uh information showed that he just
recently got married
so this is yet another very very
disastrous and very sad story that we
are seeing here right now today in
taiwan
that is so heartbreaking william and i
think we're probably going to get to
learn
some more of those stories um you
mentioned the current death toll
is that expected to rise
yes unfortunately i think that number
could be going up more
as more of the very seriously injured
passengers
are still being treated in nearby
hospitals and a lot of them uh have
injuries that could uh threaten their
lives later on
so the next few hours will be very
critical and i think the numbers
could go up over the next few hours dws
william yang
joining us from taiwan and william will
continue to check in with you thanks for
your reporting
thank you
you